welcome
to this free webinar on omix logic data
science
in today's session our team will be
sharing
information examples and an overview of
omix logic training resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from current topics
in biomedical research
in this webinar we will introduce
biomedical
data analysis techniques and approaches
that you can master
and adopt to help you conduct better
research
and learn about how data science is
changing
medical research from diagnosis to
treatment selection
and development of new therapeutics
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omics logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of
users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community
managed by buying biotech now before
i move on i
want to ask you to take this poll which
you can now see
on your screens
the first question of this poll is what
country
are you from you can choose from this
list
i hope everyone can see the poll on the
screen
you can put it in the poll if you do not
see your country listed you can put that
down
in the chat box thank you so much kony
and abdullah
for letting me know and athera i see
that
you cannot hear any sound you can leave
the zoom meeting and join back again
with
zoom audio that would be helpful
okay we have a lot of participants from
india and there are a lot of other
countries which
i can see
so lydia is from malta with all from
brazil
abeed is from malaysia franco javier is
from peru
iraq brazil so we have a lot of
participants from
different parts of the world and if we
move on to the second question it is
what is your level of education
the first is high school the second is
bachelor's degree
third master's degree phd and then there
are other degrees
which you may have taken
you can just uh select the
answer that is suited to yourself
thank you ashwini for letting us know
the third answer question is your
area of interest so you can choose
between these different datas
bioinformatics biotechnology
cell and molecular biology computer
science data science infectious diseases
oncology and others
this poll is going to help us learn more
about our audience today
and the last question is what are you
expecting to get
from this webinar today so are you
looking forward to learn more about data
science learn about
introduction to machine learning tools
learn about bioinformatics programming
in r
and python or acquire new skills
so i'll keep the poll on for about
another minute and we will then continue
with
today's session
okay so thank you everyone
for voting and for sharing your answers
with us
thank you harsh for sharing uh about
your
interest and ashwini as well
thank you dr dina
so i will be ending the poll now and if
you have
any other answers or if you want to
share with us you can please
put your answers down in the chat box
so moving on
i would like to start by introducing
pine biotech the company behind
omix logic and share with you details
about the upcoming omics logic programs
and explain
how the training resources we will
discuss today will be used
in this data science program
so omits logic is a program for
bioinformatics training
that was developed in collaboration
between prime biotech
and october bioinformatics research
center
what we will discuss today is a result
of hard work by an
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr alfred tober
and dr leonid rotsky dr alfred tober
comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation and has
been recognized internationally for his
generous support of
many research projects and initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
tobor bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics he has numerous
publications in mathematics and
bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science
and training and some of our team will
be presenting today as well over the
course of the past
several years our team has been
collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omics
logic programs have been thoroughly
evaluated and are known to lead to
excellent outcomes importantly the
programs
are designed to support students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by
mentors and peer example developing
a growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
the program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical analysis and
machine learning and a broad overview of
technologies and project examples
to learn about and develop practical
data science skills using user-friendly
cloud technologies as well as r and
python coding
so who is this program for this program
is designed for students
starting from the undergraduate level to
faculty and researchers
from both biology and clinician
backgrounds
who can participate to learn more about
data science and biomedical research
and as i see from the chats today and
from the board there are a lot of
faculty a lot of researchers as well as
students who have joined us for this
webinar
now let me introduce you to your mentors
in the upcoming omics logic program you
will have the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
uh am i not audible no you're audible
website i think
some people have trouble connecting to
audio
okay thank you so much elia
so in the upcoming omics logic program
as i was saying you will have the
opportunity to interact and collaborate
with our international team of experts
who are specialized in the
application of data science to
biological data sets
so let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified
omix logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician
and will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist participants with
projects and analysis during
the program her area of specialization
is cancer genomics
and machine learning dr mohit mazundar
is our omits logic project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with
industry and academia ilia protski
fine market co-founder and ceo in his
current role has
extensive experience working together
with industrial academic partners that
are applying
multi-omics integration and info
bioinformatics to
a variety of biotechnology and clinical
applications
i would now like to invite elia to talk
about the
increasing significance of data science
in biomedical research
and introduce you to the types of
challenges we will be addressing
in this upcoming program over to you
elia
thank you bipsap and thank you everyone
for joining so first of all
i wanted to share the polling results so
that we can look
at the data so we see here that many of
you
have either a masters or a phd
in various domains and i think this is
especially going to be important
as we're going to be speaking about data
science
which includes some specialization in a
particular domain so we'll talk about
that in a second
and secondly in the third question you
can see that
many of you are interested in
bioinformatics so we'll kind of start
from there we'll talk about the
relationship between
data science and bioinformatics what's
new what's different and how those two
domains relate to each other but also
many of you have already a
specialization in biotechnology cell
molecular biology
and other biomedical research domain so
i think that's very important
and as many of you are expecting to
learn about data science
in this webinar i think what we are
trying to do
is balance an informational webinar that
will give you a broad perspective on
data science
in application to biomedical data
but also to introduce you to a lot of
tools and resources that you can
leverage on your own
between now and when the program
actually starts and i'll go through some
of those examples
in my presentation but then when i pass
it on to other co-presenters
i will i'm sure that they will share a
lot more technical detail
okay so let's start i'm going to
close the poll and share my screen
so let's get started what is
data data science
which is what this webinar is dedicated
to is really a convergence
of data or data management and
manipulation
sometimes referred to as wrangling or
data handling effectiveness
analytical methods for hypothesis
testing and statistical inference
and some kind a specialization domain
so that domain could be biological
research finance marketing clinical
business internet of things a number of
different things and so typically when
people say
data science they apply data
manipulation and data management
technologies and statistical inference
to a variety of different domains so in
a lot of senses
data science is broad and then
we can compare this to bioinformatics
bioinformatics
is essentially the same thing because
when we speak about informatics it's an
older term that rose to prominence
in maybe the 80s and the 90s when
information technologies
was really the key term and so when we
speak about data management essentially
that's information technologies
and statistical inference including
analytical methods and machine learning
all fall under the same domain of using
data analytics to gain insights into
some
phenomena but specifically
bioinformatics is focused on biological
phenomena
and in today's world the biological data
has been tremendously changing so let's
see how has this data been changing
well one of the emerging trends after
the emergence of high throughput
technologies that have
started originating in the biomedical
research domain from the human genome
project is the emergence of big data
and we're not just talking about big
data files
that are maybe instead of megabytes now
or gigabytes and size
now we're talking about a whole stream
of data
that is increasingly complex because
a single phenomena is being
characterized
by multiple types of data and those
data are speaking about the same thing
from
different types of data perspectives so
when we speak about the nature of this
data i think it's very clear
especially in this latest pandemic that
not only has this data changed in size
changed in type it also is increasingly
real time and so i think we're entering
a
time when biomedical research data
from being a an expensive high commodity
and high value experimentation into an
ordinary stream of data that will
completely overwhelm
our ability to extract insights if
many of us who are not experts in data
science already in bioinformatics
already
cannot leverage the tools and the basic
skill sets to
manage effectively utilize analytics to
extract
insights from this data and also share
the results of our analysis effectively
so what kind of data is this higher
throughput data
collectively this data is referred to as
onyx data
so onyx data can play a
role in a variety of things that we can
capture for example
we can talk about phenomics or the way
that
biological tissues and samples look and
what are their characteristics including
clinical characteristics
we can talk about genomics or variation
at the dna sequence level
and so this data provides us insight
into per nucleotide variation
or regions of dna that have a variation
from
the reference genome we talked about
epigenomics where we can look at
histone modification and dna methylation
patterns throughout the genome and as a
result we can also look at
gene expression which is characterized
by abundance of different mrnas
non-coding rnas but also alternative
splicing events
which can help us differentiate between
different conditions and
sample types so one key area
that you deal with in bioinformatics
is the ability to understand what these
different omics data types
define and describe and how to utilize
effective processing tools or pipelines
to convert this data to structured data
so what you can see here
is a table this is a table of expression
but this table of expression can play a
serious uh challenge can become a
serious challenge when we
extract this the reads or the sequencing
digital data directly from high
throughput experiments
and so one of the primary ways that
bioinformatics has been different from
data science
is that includes an understanding of
what the signal
explains in terms of the molecular
features that it defines
and also in the deep understanding of
what algorithms do
in the process of extracting this
structured data
from individual digital signals that are
captured from the machines that produce
this data
but today this kind of data is not
again as i mentioned a commodity but
really a standard
practice across a variety of biomedical
applications including biomedical
clinical research where we look at
populations of
patients including molecular analysis
of different pathogens that cause and
drive disease progression
and an understanding of how to apply
these insights
to the domain of biotechnology
biochemistry
and clinical diagnostics where
therapeutics are developed
and characterization of these phenotypes
helps us understand clinical pathologies
so what we want to do in this program
and where we invite you to really join
for
hands-on sessions training guided by our
mentors
and a variety of resources that you will
gain
access to and we'll describe those in
detail in just a few minutes
is really a complete roadmap for
data science in application to
biomedical research data
where we will cover important topics
like finding data sets
being able to explore and visualize
these complex data sets
understand research methods as you
review publications
and gain insights and understanding and
so importantly
this is a road map from the very
beginning
to application and we're hoping that
many of you that maybe have
minimal understanding of what data
science is or minimal experience
practically applying bioinformatics to
these types of challenges
will be able to do this for the first
time but also for those of you that
probably
have heard about rna-seq have heard
about
metagenomic data have heard about
genomic variation
you will be able to see how combining
these technologies together
and becoming effective with data
manipulation data wrangling
effective processing of this large data
and then analytics and machine learning
you can really gain
insights into some of the pressing
challenges that surround us
including in application to a variety of
domains
like oncology infected infectious
diseases
and complex conditions that might not
even have
a direct clinical application so onyx
logic
is really like a map it's a map that
will take you from
where you are right now asking questions
about your current background
interest and focus into the field of
data science
where molecular data omics data
can become logically clear so that your
analytical capabilities could be applied
to extract
interesting insights from a variety of
different example
projects and so a big part of what we
provide in this program
is not just the training on how to apply
these different omnics
technologies but provide you with
curated examples
that include diagnostics and cancer
biology
look at single cell and tissue
composition as well as microbiome and
infection
you'll find this in the context of
different projects that you can get
started with
and then carry on to introduce them as a
starting point for your own
research project as you develop them
throughout these programs
what we'll look at as the context of
this process of applying
data science methodology is the process
for
understanding how the data was
collecting
was collected what was the experimental
design
to then processing and cleaning and
preparing the data for analysis
performing exploratory data analysis
where you can visualize
and mine this data for patterns and then
taking it to
data analysis stage where you have
different statistical methods
or machine learning tools which
essentially represent
a model that could be trained to provide
you with insights
into an inference so biologically
interpretable
insights that you can demonstrate and
also
share as a replicable process so that
data sharing is effective
so let's look at some of these methods
in a little bit
greater detail what we want to cover
in this section is preparation of data
and once the data is prepared
how do we select from the many tools
that are available out there and
probably many of you have heard about
or maybe even applied with a deeper
understanding
of what are some of the logical
components
of these methods what situations
to use when we apply the different
methodologies
and how to combine them together so that
we
gain insights into our data sets and can
translate that insight into a next
decision potentially about selecting the
next method of analysis
as an example we can look at gene
expression profiling
right we can look at differential gene
expression which is a very simple
example
of a statistical comparison but we can
also apply clustering techniques to help
make that data visually more presentable
we can use principal component analysis
to explore variability between samples
but we can also design our experiment to
now
use that insight to eliminate outliers
look at very defined groups of samples
and ask questions about
what are the features that help us
understand the differences between
samples so these are just some of the
examples that we will use
but in the greater context you will see
how bioinformatics
and big data will bring out the
important characteristics for use
in clinical and therapeutic applications
to a variety of biomedical research
problems and so we'll illustrate these
problems
using different examples to speak about
one of these examples and give you a
clear
understanding of what we mean by curated
data sets
i want to pass the microphone over to dr
harpreet kahr
who has an extensive background in
genomic research and application to
cancer
specifically to uh to liver cancer so
dr i'll pass it on to you
thank you
let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is the its high mortality rate
and lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is considered as sixth major
malignancy in terms of incidence
and fourth in terms of mortality
worldwide
liver cancer is often at times
misdiagnosed
or detected to lead for any effective
treatment
another factor that contribute
to our outcome of the liver cancer
patient is the frequent reoccurrence of
tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
seen number of research objectives
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using various bioinformatics techniques
for example in the first project
we used last scale transcriptomics data
to identify a diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy so in this
study
we employed nearly 30 data sets
containing nearly four thousand sample
the lucity transcriptomics biomarker
panel
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
implementing various statistical
and machine learning techniques like
svm random forest knee base etc
for the next part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data of scc patients to scrutinize
scrutinize omics features
that can discriminate
basins based on its stages that is early
and the latest here we employ
tcga data of nearly 350 basin
to elucidate 51 features that
include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpg
sites that can distinguish early stage
and nasty sample based on various
bioinformatics approaches
in the third part of this project we use
transcriptomics data
to scrutinize diagnostic biomarker panel
that is specific for chlangiocarcinoma
which is another major liver malignancy
here we employ 9 data set
containing 350 chlangiocarcinoma
133 adjacent non-tumorous
cholangiocarcinoma patients and 90 scc
patient samples two secretinized
chlangiocarcinomas specific
transcriptomic signature
implementing a number of data mining
techniques
like random forest logistic regression
extra tree
lda etc
so conclusively in this
whole study we have identified
a three gene based biomarker for the
hcc that can discriminate scc samples
from the normal samples
and then we have elucidated three ccs
pacific signatures
that can discriminate clean your
carcinoma sample
from normal as well as ssc samples
in the next part we have identified a 50
51 multi omics features that include 30
rna transcripts
and 21 methylation cpg site
that that can discriminate early and the
latest
of hcc samples
so in my current role i am omiks logic
bioinformatics trainer with the pioneer
i am assisting participants to learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to the large data sets
in biomedical research besides we are
designing
various research projects using publicly
available datasets
so in continuation to the liver cancer
research
here we have designed a research project
based on the multi-omics data of liver
cancer
patients to find out the molecular
signatures
that are associated with the clinical
and the demographic
phenotypes of the liver cancer patients
here we explored different omics data
from the tcdl like rna
mi rna and clinical data of the liver
cancer patients
in this project we have implemented
various
multi omics data integration tools
like snf i cluster plus
or to pls that are in already available
on t bind for server
so here we are trying to understand how
multi-omics data integration analysis
can provide us the holistic picture of
this lethal malignancy
and also how they are associated with
the diverse
clinical and demographic phenotypes of
the patients
like their tumor stays risk factors
and gender of the patients etc
participants can explore this project
during the upcoming data science program
i'm looking forward to being your mentor
in the
upcoming omics logic data science
program
now i would like pass this session to dr
mohit
who is our project mentor so
over to dr mohit and if you have any
question you can post your questions in
the chat box
and we will address those questions okay
so over to you dr mohit
thank you dr apreet okay let me share my
screen
hello everyone uh my name is mohit
and as you know by now that i'm one of
the
global representatives of pine biotech
and in my current role
i am working with undergraduate
postgraduate and phd students uh
scientists and researchers for
bioinformatics research
and training and in this process
collaborating with universities in india
and
africa to provide support in in
research so i have completed my phd in
computational biology and have been
actively working with academia and
industry to solve important research
problems
using tools and technology that suits
best for the problem
today uh the world is seeing the
biomedic
the world is seeing biomedical data
science as a great opportunity
actually to solve some of the unanswered
questions
that require our immediate attention
so talking about big data in bio biology
so big data in biology has an important
role in shaping
our understanding of living beings
better
most impacted by this change in the
is the area of genomic medicine where it
is now possible to move from
generating reference or population level
data to producing data from
individuals right and we have been
seeing this uh
as one of the case that is ongoing with
the
with the different strains of kovite
coming in genomic
uh understanding and sequencing is
playing huge road
in identification of those strains and
as it is it has been like data has
always been an integral part of life
sciences
but with the availability of
computational power now
and the volume of the heterogeneity of
this data
has also increased immensely so i mean
it
complements each other in a way and to
make
sense of this large volume of data
available
i think a biologist or a computational
biologist need to be able to know the
processes
and the methodologies to interpret this
data
and understand the patterns and where
and that's like maybe
the biggest challenge right now for
biologists and bioinformaticians
so if you see in this data survey you'll
find out that
of course ai and big data have the
biggest
impact
however to understand this application
and to be able to find
information from this big data it is
sort of important to learn about the
analysis strategy
and get experience working on this real
data sets
so together with our research
collaborators from topper bioinformatics
research center
uh lsu and uh ucsf we have
prepared projects for you one of the
projects was highlighted by dr apreet as
well
which she has prepared along with our
team so this projects
will help you will take you through a
project-based approach we call
and where we take data sets from high
impact publications
and use them for practical exp exercises
so it's kind of you know difficult to
imagine exactly
what the biomedical industry will look
like in in years time but if you can see
this
uh image and you can see that how
bioinformatics has
been helping transforming basic sciences
into translational research projects
so there have been a lot of large
innovative research projects which are
ongoing one of such a research project
is international human
cell atlas initiative 10 that aims to
create
comprehensive reference map of all human
cells
so we are also collecting information
from devices
apps variables and implant
implantable technologies right so in
this
data science program uh we will learn
about
analysis strategies that i just
discussed and methods
by getting hands-on experience working
on real data sets
that explains these challenges in for
example precision medicine so this is an
example of precision medicine
and with this uh understanding of what
the authors have achieved and what the
data set is about
and why this publication is important in
the context of
breast cancer where they have where the
authors have collected
uh so many data sets on cell lines and
have
concluded would be a journey that we
would
take you through during this program to
be able to learn about this project
itself
so it involves like several methods as i
was telling you that the data sets come
from cell lines
then we have other features like we have
the
uh the drug response so combining these
features and understanding the
application like cancer is a complex
disease right and what we have been
doing so far
is to be able to understand the disease
from a single
uh aspect yesterday we had a meeting
with one of
our uh interns working on uh important
aspect of
breast cancer you know classification
understanding applying machine learning
methods
and we realized that the patterns that
we see from one analysis
is not sufficient to help us understand
uh
you know what is going on so there
integration of multiple data sets
and that has been one of the key
features of today's walls bioinformatics
multi-omics integration
helps so
during our omics logic programs and in
this data science program
we will learn and we will be using
uh different components that are
connected together
and we will in in this way we will
combine online sessions
and we we will use self-guided study
materials
and practical assignments for this
immersive experience
that has been proven to be very
effective and we have been working with
hundreds of students and interns who are
working and doing great
uh with the projects that they are
working on and that i will be discussing
in couple of slides
so the program itself has a theoretical
materials
that you will be able to find out on
this
website so let me take you to the
website
and the program page the organization
page
where we will find all these resources
that are associated with this program
all right so this is the organization
page and
uh this is on our educational platform
and this educational platform is a
unique platform because it comprises of
in in itself it comprises of a classroom
and it has all the resources that you
would need
to go forward and start this
understanding of this
entire program using this
different resources that we will be
discussing now so uh the first page
and i think um yeah thank you
if you have shared the link yeah
so in the first page you will see that
uh there are several sections within
this
uh program so you have home you have
forum
you have courses you have projects you
have syllabus
assignments and then you have resources
user projects progress
events faculty members and managers so
you kind of have a overview of
all the components here in this page so
you can start by browsing and once you
have the access you will be
able to see this that the sessions are
the upcoming sessions that
will be coming up one after another and
we this is like needed to be updated
but we also have a forum here and where
we can
track and we can see individual progress
like what i have been doing
what i have been learning what i have
been finishing so
i have a specific profile similarly each
of the participants on
or or the users who register on this
part on this platform
gets an academic profile so this
academic profile or portfolio shows your
achievements that you have gained
throughout this program and can be
showcased as a profile on your
uh on your cv or on your
on your linkedin profile so
moving on to the next tab
you will see courses so these are the
courses that have been already added
that you will have access to once you
register so
you can go through these courses to
develop an understanding of how
multi-omics data
is helpful and then their application of
omics data by using machine learning so
transcriptomics three is about that
so where we are using supervised machine
learning and unsupervised machine
learning on a table
so that table is table of expression in
this example
in transcriptomics so as you will see
from the courses
uh then there are projects that are the
next
stage after doing the courses because
here you are
learning about the application so uh how
this
uh these technologies
are applied uh to a specific research
so learning from project examples and
then you have the syllabus
and one of the i mean important aspect
of this program
is the interactive nature of this
program which i'll be discussing in
a lot more detail later on but to tell
you about this that
uh we kind of have a point system
that helps us uh understand that
what have i i mean how much have i
learned throughout this process
so the platforms that you will be using
and i'll be coming to that
in the next slide that we will be using
this educational platform where you can
you are going to take courses and pro
and go through projects
and at the same time uh we will be using
a server platform where we can run our
experiments
and a coding platform where we can run
our codes so all of them are connected
here
uh in this page and you will see your
progress
and the progress of the entire group and
we will be able to see and work together
to achieve uh results that
helps us with that helps us with a
better outcome
from this program so as i was uh
promising you about the different
platforms so the next platform that i
wanted to discuss is the tower
bioinformatics
research platform so let me go back to
my presentation
and go through the
courses how the courses actually look
like
so we kind of review important
terminologies and provide a prospective
from experts on these exciting fields so
each course
has quizzes that allows you to see how
much you have
learned and assignments for hands-on
practice
so these assignments are also uh being
also helps you to understand the coding
behind this
so how practical skills help find
answers to
biological questions and as i was
telling you that this
program is project oriented uh with
real data sets uh use cases and
examples adopted from high impact
publications
so projects are extracted from relevant
publications on topics that
fit the program and student profiles so
it's kind of customizable so you can
choose
your research topic if you're interested
in infectious diseases learning about
uh biological aspects of that if you're
interested in
neuro degenerative diseases if you're
interested
in learning about um agriculture the
application of
data science and big data in agriculture
and obviously we have several other
examples as well
so these are some of the data types that
you can see on
on the left and then some project
examples
and the next step after doing this like
these courses kind of lead you
into multiple projects uh from the
courses to the projects
and this serves as a springboard into
the world of bioinformatics
so uh with this information uh let me
pass it
on to miss beepsha uh to talk about the
important deadlines and maybe
uh and tell you about the program
registration options
and after that i will uh i will take you
to the t by info platform
and show you how the t-band for platform
is
helping us to do these kind of research
and
and we will discuss about the other
platform which is the
which is the coding platform and how
this entire
program is is going to work
as a participant point of view so over
to you
uh beepsha uh thank you so much
dr mohit
so i hope that uh everybody has gotten
an overview
of the different resources that you will
have access to
during this program and we will be
sharing the other highlights very very
soon
now let me show you the registration
process for this program
so this is the registration link and i
will post the link in the chat box
if you have already registered for this
webinar via the link then we have all of
your
uh information yes uh step two so we
will be emailing everyone the video
recording of this
session as well so once you are in this
page
this is the pre-registration page so if
you're interested in joining the program
you can actually register via this page
so if you go down this page let me take
you section by section
uh you will have some description about
the program
then the different topics that the
program will be covering
you also have the full schedule of the
program so the program is starting on
the january
on january 12th and will end on
february 11th it is a one month program
and each week we will have two sessions
at uh 9 a.m cst on these dates
for more details uh please fill out this
form
so that you will be receiving an
email with all the different information
that you need
to register yourself to the program and
also the other
necessary details so once you are
registered here
you can of course go ahead and check all
of these
different uh sections in this page so
once you've registered here you will be
redirected to this page so now this is
the
checkout page as you can see so in this
page all you have to do is
click on pricing or get started either
of it
will lead you here now you see we have
three options we have also explained
what are each of these three options
and what do they mean so all of these
three membership options will give you
access to this program
the only difference in the basic
uh intermediate and advanced is the
mentor support and the project support
that you get
so in the beginner program you will have
access to the courses that dr mohit has
shown you
access to the code playground the online
sessions
and the three asynchronous projects so
these are the
asynchronous projects that you can do
so you will have access to all of them
the intermediate program on the other
hand gives you
access to a mentor who would be
available for you during this one month
session
and you can have a one-on-one meeting
with your mentor
to discuss any questions that you may
have or
even ask any questions and clear doubts
so
this is beyond the group session so that
is the benefit
of the intermediate membership while the
advanced membership give me a moment i
think
while the advanced membership gives you
access to not just the mentor support
but also
an extended 30 days of access
to this program which means you have two
months of access to the program
for 365 usd and
the opportunity to work on a novel
project of your own and i will be
showing you
some examples of these projects which
have been developed as part of these
programs and part of our
different other programs in the recent
past
so this is what the difference in the
three membership level means but if you
are a beginner and you are just looking
forward
to start with a program and learn about
data science we definitely recommend the
beginner license to start with
for any questions you can always reach
out to me marketing
at pine.bio with these questions
and for faculties uh or researchers who
would want to
uh discuss more you can reach out to dr
mohit at mohit
pine dot bio for facilitating
these programs in universities or for
your students
so now as i promised you that i would be
talking about the different project
examples
so here is a project example you can
also take a look at this project example
later
so our project development is a
step-by-step process
where we first train everyone and then
each of these participants they can
propose their own project
and they will be developing the project
along with the help of a mentor so as
you can see that
these are some of the recent projects
that were completed in 2020
this is by one of our intern and two of
our other program members who
collaborated
to make this project we have other
projects as well
so these projects uh range from
different topics like
neuroscience to infectious diseases to
oncology
to even covet right now so as you can
see there are several
project examples and these are all novel
projects that were developed
by either our research interns or by
program members
and you can have a look at all of these
different projects and watch the videos
as
the participants present them
so please have a look through this and
now
i would like to pass this on to elia
to take forward today's session ilya
over to you
thank you sir so now i'm
sure that all of you are ready to get
started
and so to give you a taste of what we
will be doing during the
actual program uh please visit
this website code.omicslogic.com
beeps if you could please post that link
and you can register here for free so
before we start the program we want you
to know what you will be
doing throughout the different sessions
that we'll be conducting
uh please let me know once you're
registered
again this is free registration so you
will see
the landing page and you can
uh log in by clicking here on get
started
and creating an account so please let me
know
once you are here so that i can show you
a couple of
examples of uh scripting challenges that
we'll be doing in
r and in python during the program
itself
okay so please let me know by putting in
the number one
once you have registered on code
omixlogic.com
hmm
all right thank you lydia so if you're
already in there you will see
these two courses introduction to data
science in
r and introduction to data science in
python okay so for those of you that are
registering right now
and see that a few of you are getting
registered right now
you should be able to see some of the
introductory courses
here for data science so let's take a
look first at this course introduction
to data science
all right great thank you subdues
so as we discussed the very first step
is to actually load some data so many of
you probably already know how to load
data but i know that for me personally
when i was getting started with r
that was one of the major challenges in
most of the tutorials you will find how
to write hello world
you will find how to do some
multiplication and addition
but if i want to take a data set that i
understand
how it was created what does it mean i
want to be able to load that data set
so to do that let's go ahead and start
by
going to this first one where you will
see
how to import data directly into a
coding session
that we will do here in just a second so
you can
go and read through this introduction
click on next
and see a few options of how to actually
load the data for example
you can load a table a txt
table you can load an excel sheet
or a spreadsheet in csv format
now let's try to do it ourselves we have
here a couple of examples
if you are doing this on your computer
and probably you'll be doing in some
kind of a developer environment
like rstudio but here we are going to do
it directly in the browser
so you can see here how you can load the
data
by adding a link a url
or a path to your data and we have an
example data set right here so you can
copy this link
paste it right here sorry paste it right
here
okay make sure that you keep the
apostrophes
and then click on run okay so you can
see
that as a result when i print df
which is what is in my object because r
is a an object oriented language i can
print df
and it shows me what's in the table so
you have
specimen one two three four and then
some
columns flower tree and bird so this is
some biological data
that describes what's inside now as you
know
in excel it works a little bit
differently
so you can see here for example let's
copy this link
and put it right here one of the things
that is different about
excel is that excel can have multiple
sheets inside it so here we only have
one sheet so it's very easy
but if you have many sheets you can
start working with
multiple sheets inside your data set so
those are some of the basic things
that you want to get familiar with is
just how to load different data sets
now as we showed before many of these
data sets
are already available in a process
structured
format on ncbi
one of the things that you can use and
we'll quickly go through this example
right here
is using principal component analysis
we can understand variability
between samples how do we do that
so if you go to this third course
dimensionality reduction pcn
visualization
you can scroll through and see an
example of a gene expression table
so here you can see genes
samples these are names of different
cell lines
and here they are grouped by their
phenotype
and their phenotype is a subtype of
triple negative breast cancer
normal like basal luminol cloud and
so four different subtypes you can read
more about this specific data set
click on next and now let's look about
learn a little bit about what this uh
uh what these different packages will do
to help us
visually explore this complex data set
why is it complex
because we have at least 15 different
genes
each one has some pattern of up and down
regulation of that
gene and we are asking the question
how does this pattern help us understand
what these samples
are or how do they compare to each other
so there is a code breakdown that we'll
skip here for a second
but here you can see an example output
and in the example output on this
principal component
by plot you can see the separation of
samples
into multiple groups and you can see
that there are a lot of samples there's
over 50 samples in this case now
just having black dots is not very
useful so we can add
labels but since we don't remember what
each one of these labels stands for
maybe what's useful is to also color
those samples
by group type so now as we get to this
uh example we'll see how to run
principal component analysis and how to
make the most
out of our visualization and as a result
you will see here an example
of what we will produce a
three-dimensional plot
with multiple groups colored multiple
groups of samples
colored by their type so you can see
here
green is basal blue dark blue is cloudy
low
and pink luminal and then light blue
normally
okay so as you will see throughout this
code
it is fairly simple just like we did
when we load the data
it is very straightforward you take the
code that is already here you can run it
and you can see
what the output will look like now as
you will try
you will start seeing different types of
outputs
for example here you can see an output
of that principal component analysis in
a two-dimensional
uh plot by plot is what it's called you
will see the groups are circled
and you'll also see that the variability
between samples
is calculated and placed on the x and
the y axis
beyond the basics which is down here you
will find
additional options that such analysis
can give you and that includes some
clustering options
a better understanding of confidence
of these different groups or how certain
we are that these groups actually
separate the way that they're described
and also some additional methods for
trying to interpret how do the
individual features or genes in this
case
can help us understand the variability
that we observe in this principle
component analysis
so this is a brief explanation of what
this data science program will actually
look like
so in this example we looked at an r
script we'll do the same
for python and we will also go
into more advanced visualization machine
learning
and biological interpretation beyond
this
you will also gain access to courses
that deal with specific data types
including genomic data
metagenomic data transcriptomic data so
you will actually be able to go
in different into different examples
understand
what this transcriptomic data describes
see the specifics of visualization
and interpretation for these different
types of data
and also get introduced to specific
projects as described in this session
so again i welcome you to join us for
this upcoming program
and i hope that this presentation gives
you a clear understanding
of what this program will provide for
you as well as
how you can try to apply these types of
methods to go into
your own area of research so again as
beeps mentioned
if you want a detailed description of
how we will cover these topics
in the different interactive sessions
just like we did today
you can go to this page and look through
the schedule
so the program will start on january 12
and it will continue
all the way until february 11th after
which point
you will be able to work on an
independent
project as was shown by vipsa and by
mohit
so in those independent projects what
you will do is you will
learn how to find the data set on ncbi
it will be a publicly available
domain public domain data set
you will then go through the specific
details of how this data set was
prepared to understand the biological
context
apply some of the methods that we have
described in and learned
throughout the sessions and then
interpret that result
now to understand what a final product
looks like
beeps has already shared the example but
i
also want to ask you to take a look
at our youtube channel where we have a
lot of examples of student projects
after they have completed their uh
training
and also join our network which is
on linkedin and on facebook so beeps if
you could please
post those links so three links
youtube channel the facebook and the
linkedin groups
and also if you could again post the
link to the data science program
registration
this is the pre-registration link and
the actual registration link is data
science.onyxlogic.com
where you will find all of the details
of final registration
and now we would love to hear any
feedback
or any questions that you might have so
that we can answer
any questions or anything that was
confusing during the session
we can clarify
yes and all the links will be sent to
your email as well
all right great so thank you any other
questions we will
try to address by email we also have a
live chat
on our website so you are welcome to ask
any questions along the way
we're looking forward to your
participation as you have seen we have
multiple
ways that you can benefit from the
resources that we've prepared
you can either do it independently on
your own a synchronous time
many of you have already registered on
the different websites that we have
so you can explore there what types of
exercises are available
what data sets are available what
projects are available
and then if you're interested in a
mentor-guided interactive session
you're welcome to join the full program
and also request
a one-on-one guided session with a
mentor and
also we have research opportunities for
those of you that are interested in
developing independent projects
so please do reach out to us about those
details
thank you and we hope to continue
and see you in our network
so
you